[Music]
Jerusalem is the seat of Israel's
government today we follow through on
this recognition and open our embassy in
the historic and sacred land of
Jerusalem President Trump by recognizing
history you have made history we are in
Jerusalem and we are here to stay
Israel is a sovereign nation with the
right to determine its own capital the
same right that is enjoyed by every
other country in the world we also
witnessed today a ceremony of the Prime
Minister of Israel and the
administration of President Trump
burying the peace process burying the
two-state solution killing the hope in
the minds of the people of the Middle
East as a whole were the possibility of
peace well it was a campaign promise and
it has been delivered the u.s. embassy
movement from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem
other countries have followed suit or in
the process of doing that the United
States is the first one but Guatemala
this week Paraguay Honduras Romania has
a proposal to move its embassy would be
the first EU member to do so very soon
Democrats supporting this Chuck Schumer
the Senate Minority Leader saying in a
long-overdue move we have moved our
embassy to Jerusalem every nation should
have the right to choose its capital I
sponsored a legislation to do this two
decades ago and I applaud President
Trump for doing so obviously there were
other people who had a real problem with
it including many Palestinians who took
to the streets today
some 40,000 Palestinians staged
demonstrations along the border more
than 50 people were killed in the
rioting there 2,300 wounded and some of
the Arab Street weighing in on all of
that today as well let's bring in our
panel Steve Hays editor in chief for The
Weekly Standard moralizing national
political correspondent of National
Public Radio Molly Hemingway senior
editor at The Federalist and we welcome
former National Security Council
spokesman Michael and Tom Oh Michael let
me start with you this was the plan for
a long time had it been has it gone and
as plam do you think it's more than a
campaign promise first of all this is US
law for I think 23 years passed in
295 and this is one of the things I just
want to point out that I think drives
middle America the average American
crazy about Washington the Congress
passes a law with overwhelming
bipartisan support puts a waiver
provision in it so the will of the
people through their elected
representatives is that this should
happen and every six months every
president waives it waives it waives and
it never happens it's a kind of theater
in a way and then a president finally
fulfills the terms of the law and you
saw this yes he's got some support but a
lot of his political his domestic
political critics you know level all
kinds of accusations at him when I
thought as to terms of the law this was
a bipartisan consensus for two decades
so on the bigger picture Mara on the
Middle East peace process and where this
goes
what is this do to that well I think
that's the big question kind of now what
it's not unlike getting out of the Iran
deal okay now what are you going to do
next the Middle East peace proposal from
the Trump administration has yet to be
unveiled as you heard the Palestinian
leader they're not inclined to enter
talks now they feel the United States is
no longer an honest broker it's just
totally on Israel's side so I think now
the ball is in the president's court and
he has to come up with the next steps
for Middle East peace if that's what he
wants if he just wanted to fulfill a
campaign promise he has certainly done
that well I think it is awful to see
what we saw the loss of life with so
many Palestinians being killed and the
Washington Post had reported that they
were told that Hamas had told them that
Israel was not Manning these these sites
on the border and it was causing people
to rush and then they found out that
they were manned that is a very sad
thing and it's it's a it's not fun to
watch it is also true though that I
think that this could in the long term
lead to a greater chance for peace we
have we have the reality that Jerusalem
is the capital of Israel and it is
important that everyone acknowledge that
and it's time for Palestinians to
acknowledge that and that dealing with
reality is a good way to get move
forward toward a peace agreement which
people hope for Steve there there are
other things taking place from behind
the scenes around a subterranean level
that suggests that there is that there
is some move toward peace I mean when
you talk about the the talks that are
happening out of public eye between
Israel and the Saudis or the support the
common
values on the Iran deal between Israel
and Saudis Israel and UAE the Bahrain
ease stepping up and speaking out in
favor of the withdrawal from the Iran
deal I think you're seeing these moves
this gets a lot of the headlines
particularly because of the loss of life
but there are other indications that are
much more positive and and this is
something that Donald Trump campaign on
this is something that he said and I
think Mike's exactly right this is
something that you had presidents of
both parties saying for literally
decades and they didn't do it he did it
the equation of pulling out of the Iran
deal then moving the embassy and those
two things together how do they
interchange how do they interlock how do
they affect each other well I think that
first of all I just want to follow up on
a point that Steve made there I think
when you said missed an opportunity I
don't think this is that it's really the
Palestinians that are missing the
opportunity it's really the Palestinians
that need to come back to the table
that's what's important here if the
Palestinians if Mahmud Abbas would just
come back and talk to this
administration talk to his president and
sit down I think he would find an
incredible willingness and eagerness to
get a deal done I've heard president
Trump talk about this so many times you
know there's an old saying it goes
around Washington they have people who
have dealt with this issue that the
Palestinians never miss an opportunity
to miss an opportunity and that's what
they're doing now I think it's also
interesting that what you're seeing is a
lot of this coming out of Gaza which is
controlled by Hamas and run by Hamas
right and you're not seeing this kind of
at least this intensity coming out of
the West Bank right this is clearly
being ginned up for political purposes
and the White House is so concerned look
what's only a couple of weeks ago that
the White House hosted a conference on
the future of Gaza on how to improve its
infrastructure improve the lives of
people got the Gulf Arab states to show
up and and and you know pledge some aid
and these are states don't like to talk
to one another in some respect because
of the dispute in the Gulf and don't
like to be in the same room with Israeli
representatives and they were all there
I think that was another positive and
hopeful sign if only the Palestinians
would embrace the possibilities that I
think President Trump is opening up for
them I guess the question is does the
Arab Street change now because of the
different relationship with the Trump
administration in the Gulf states as
how they react to both things the Iran
deal and this move here is it does him a
reshaping in the Middle East from what
we had seen in the previous
administration with an effort to make
Iran more dominant and the but I think
it remains to be seen how they respond
tomorrow yeah I mean the I come back to
this question if if the United States is
going to be the leader and is going to
put forward a peace plan that needs to
do that the Palestinians will come to
the table if they see a good plan where
they have there something in it for them
right now they don't know what it is but
for years the Middle East peace has been
used as something to block progress in
other areas in the region if you ever
you know the foreign policy
establishment says you have to solve
Middle East peace first and then you can
address threats from Iraq you can
address jihadism you can address Ron you
can address all these other things well
I think this sends a message pretty
clearly that's not going to be an
obstacle any more take that set it to
the side and deal with threats like Iran
on a realistic basis so it changes the
paradigm it changes the starting point
well I mean Brit said it said it well
earlier in the show you're dealing with
reality here this is a more realistic
look at the way that the Middle East is
unfold one thing to is keep in mind that
Iran is a big supporter of hamas a lot
of the wealth that iran was able to take
in because of the Iran deal unfrozen
assets and then the wealth that they
were able to generate bike being allowed
to do business with countries that used
to sanction them they are spending that
to destabilize the Middle East to fund
terror they're funneling it to Hamas and
to other groups like this and hopefully
with the Iran the u.s. out of the Iran
deal perhaps some some new sanctions and
some other secondary sanctions going
back into effect some of that resource
funnel and gets choked off gets reduced
and Iran doesn't have the resources or
it has fewer resources to spread mayhem
chaos and violence the way it's been
doing we will see